Happy Thursday, everybody.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
I hope everybody is
having a great week.
If it is your first
time joining us today,
it's very nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael.
I lead our pro customer
community here at Posit.
This is an open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're facing, and
getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data
across all different industries
and companies.
So every week we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host for
the day to help
lead our discussion and
answer questions from you all.
And I'm going to
mute somebody again.
Hannah, you can help with that.
But together we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
So we love hearing from
everyone, no matter your level
of experience or area of work.
It is totally OK to just
listen in to Hangouts, too.
But we do want to hear
from you, as well.
So there's three ways
you can ask questions.
Or also provide your
own perspective.
You can jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom,
you can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
And feel free to just put
a little star next to it
if you want me to read it.
Or else I could call on you
to introduce yourself and add
some context, too.
We also have a Slido link
where you can ask questions
anonymously, and Hannah
will share that here
in the chat in just a second.
We do share the recordings of
each session up to the Posit
YouTube, so you can always
go back and rewatch or share
with a friend, too.
And there's a LinkedIn
group, as well,
which we'll share in the chat.
We've been a little
quiet in there lately,
but if it's helpful
for connecting
with people after
the fact, I encourage
you to join that group, too.
With that, thank you so
much Namrata for joining us
as the co-host today.
Namrata Shetty-Anderson is
advanced analytics manager
at the UPS store.
And I'd love to
have you maybe start
by introducing
yourself and sharing
a little bit about your work.
Maybe something you like to
do outside of work, as well.
So hi, everyone.
Really happy to be here.
I was really happy when
Rachel reached out.
This is my first data Science
Hangout as a featured leader.
I've attended a few as
one of the attendees,
and I think that's
where Rachel found me.
As she pointed out, I'm
Namrata Shetty-Anderson.
I know my name is
difficult to pronounce,
so you can call me Reddy.
That's what everyone calls
me, I'm cool with it.
I'm an advanced analytics
manager at the UPS store.
I've been with the company
for about five years now.
Actually, almost six years now.
And I lead a team
of six analysts.
And together we do
everything data.
We're the data nerds
of the organization.
And anything that has
anything to do with data
goes through us.
Whether it's bringing
data on premise,
whether it's building
reports, dashboards,
predictive analytics, machine
learning, wrangling, cleaning,
everything about data for
this organization goes to us.
In my free time, I'm boring.
So in my free time, I'm
either playing with data.
My husband has a PS5, he plays
know Call of Duty or Blast
of Fuzz or what
have you, and I'm
playing with random
data sets online
trying to learn new things.
Or I'm with my dogs.
I have two big dogs and a cat.
And they take up
most of my time.
So I'm either with my dogs
and my husband and my cat,
or I'm with data.
So that's pretty
much all about me.
I love it.
Well, thank you so
much for joining us.
And it is always really fun
to have someone new join us.
An attendee in the past
be the featured leader
for the week, too.
So excited to have you here.
I'd love to, it sounds
like so many different data
projects go through your team.
I'd love to understand a
little bit about, maybe
like an example project
that you worked on.
Sure.
I'll share what I can.
So like I said, my team
handles everything in our firm.
So we have a little bit
of what we call ourselves
as shadow ID or
data engineering.
We do a little bit of that.
We have a little
bit of descriptive
and just building reports
that kind of stuff.
And then we have
a set of us that
does predictive analytics,
forecasting, machine learning,
that kind of stuff.
So the way projects
roll into my team is,
say there's a company
project that's ongoing.
They're going to come to us
for probably KPI reporting
for that project.
So we're going to maybe
do some wrangling and Ar
and put together
an ad hoc report.
Or we also have a
Power BI Service
where we publish
dashboards for the users.
So that's where all our
descriptive stuff goes.
And then we have predictive
models for everything.
We've got, we're the
UPS store network.
So if you know about us, we
have over 5,100 locations
across the country.
So my team is in charge of
forecasting how much revenue
those stores are
going to generate,
how much volume is going to
go through these stores, what
is the customer traffic
going to look like?
Assisting with staffing for
the stores, that kind of stuff.
So we build models to assist
with those things, as well.
Thank you.
I know when I was looking
at the bio you sent
and you specifically
talked about you
get excited to tell
stories with data.
And I like the way
that you framed that.
I'm wondering, do you
have any tips for us
on how to tell better
stories with data?
Sure.
So this is something that
I've actually struggled
with in the past, I'll say.
This is something
that I learned was
an area of improvement for me.
So over the last few years, I've
really focused on this area.
So definitely I can
tell you what I know.
In my mind, data science is as
much a science as it is an art.
To be able to tell
your story, you
could write hundreds
of lines of code
and you could build
amazing models,
but at the end of the day,
if you can't translate it
to a non data person as a data
story, all that is a waste.
Right?
You're not adding any value.
Businesses don't
care about your code.
My boss doesn't care about
my hundreds of lines of code.
He wants value.
So I call it the
art of data stories.
It's telling your data
story that's an art.
So one thing I started doing,
and actually I took a course
by Kevin Hartman from
Google, which talks about how
data storytelling is an art.
And one thing I learned
from that course
is you want to start with
a solution for the problem
in a tool agnostic environment.
Don't start with your
tool when the problem
is posed in front of you.
Because what happens is the tool
is going to limit your ability
to tell your story.
If I say I'm going
to use Power BI,
then I'm going to be
limited to the visuals that
are available in Power BI.
Right?
So what I started
doing, literally,
blank page and a pen.
What do I want my
outcome to look like?
And once I know
what that story is
going to look like on
a blank sheet of paper,
then I decide what
tool I'm going to use.
Now the tool is going to
depend on how quickly do I
need to turn this around?
How complex is this task?
And how good am
I with this tool?
Right?
So those are the things
you need to look at.
So everyone's, oh,
Python's better than R,
R is better than Python.
No, Power BI is the way to go.
Tableau is the way to go.
No, everybody's right
and everybody is wrong.
Your tool of choice will
depend on the problem
you're trying to solve.
So that is what
I'm going to say.
I really love
that perspective.
I see a lot of comments
in the chat, too.
I thought about that
before too, even
when you're making
presentations,
like sometimes if you jump
straight into the slides,
you become attached to them.
Don't want to give them up
even if it wasn't the right way
to communicate it.
Yeah, and that's the thing.
Don't fall in love with
anything you're doing.
Don't fall in love with it.
Because that's what
the data world is.
Today you're doing
it one way, you're
going to find a better way to
do it as you keep learning.
There's always a better way.
Priyanka, I see you had asked
in the chat about that course,
and I was trying to find it
at the same time, as well.
Namrata, do you know what
the name of that was?
Yes.
Just give me one
second to look for it.
It was Business Analytics,
Communicating With Data
by Kevin Hartman.
And I did it on Coursera.
But it might be
offered elsewhere, too.
So I wouldn't limit
myself to Coursera.
OK.
Thank you.
Marlene, I see you
have your hand raised.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
Hi.
Good morning.
Or afternoon, I don't
know where everybody's at,
so it could be evening.
If you're 8 hours
ahead, I apologize.
Hello to whatever day you're in.
Namrata, thank you.
I mean, I'm already digging
all the things you're saying.
Much love to just throwing
the box away and starting
with a new box instead of
thinking outside the box,
in the box, et cetera.
So my question is
kind of targeted.
And I don't want you
to feel like you're
giving up trade secrets,
because that's not
what I'm probing for.
But so my mom used to work
for UPS in loss prevention
for many moons.
Like she was there for
I think 28 odd years.
Wow.
And it's really cool,
though, because she
was kind of a pioneer.
I have to say that, I think
it's one of the qualities
that I hope I inherited from
her, or she's a bit of a sleuth
and wants to provide
solutions to problems.
So one thing she did though,
this was back on pen and paper,
where she used to do
credit card fraud tracking.
So she would take known
credit card fraud addresses is
what she called her.
Called it, excuse me.
Where some, she used to
work in the downtown La hub
here in Los Angeles.
And she used to say,
OK, there's this one
address in the middle of like
a not so good neighborhood.
And there are five credit cards
that are all sending stuff
to the same address.
And she would do this by hand.
And then eventually when I
was very early on in my data
analytics career, I built
her a little database
so she could easily look
stuff up and see duplicates
for a single address,
things like that.
And it wound up saving
like millions of dollars.
I didn't realize until at
the end of the year one year.
Her boss came and
said, do you realize
we got a letter from
Disney that said
that you've saved
them $5 million
this year because of all like.
People would send, for example,
tickets to Disneyland in boxes
to these addresses bought
on stolen credit cards
or fraudulent credit cards.
And for those of you familiar
with southern California,
we have Knott's Berry Farm.
Around October, we
have not Scary Farm,
which is a really big
event for a theme park.
Also hundreds of
thousands of dollars
she would save them from
fraudulent tickets being sold
and purchased on credit cards.
So what I'm getting
to, I'm sorry,
it's a very long backstory.
I feel the same way too,
it's like an epic back
story and then a punch line.
How has maybe the
analytics for that,
have you started
to see that maybe
make their way to
your team or you
can maybe on a national
scale or even a global scale
kind of understand
the fraud part of it?
And/or, because it's easy
to do just like sales
profit loss that way.
But I found credit card fraud
really cool in that respect,
because it's just a little
niche pocket of saved revenue,
we'll say.
Or loss overhead
prevention, right?
So anyway, that's
kind of my question.
Yes that sounds very cool.
That sounds a very cool
project you worked on.
And your mom worked on.
So the UPS store is
a subsidiary of UPS.
So I'm not as involved
on the UPS side of things
as I am on the store
side of things.
Although, I'm learning.
I'm learning, I'm starting
to make that transition.
But yes, fraud detection is
one project that we actually
worked on last year, but it
was a different kind of fraud.
For sensitivity
reasons, I can't share
the details of that project.
But we did have fraudulent
behavior happening
in the stores, and
we were able to use
our point of sale database
to actually help identify.
Not pinpoint the fraud activity,
but identify the likelihood
that hey, this seems like
something we want to go
and question.
And I'm not even exaggerating.
So we started last year in
April is where our finance
team came to my group
and said, hey, look,
we're seeing this behavior.
What can we do?
So we built a
dashboard that does,
it gives them all
this information.
You could see on
an outlier graph
the fraud activity for April,
for April and March was
a huge spike.
And there were spikes even
rolling 12-months before that.
So it's been
happening for a while.
Once we addressed it with
this report, two months
later up until now, it's
like a straight line.
So whatever action was
driven by that data,
helped us kind of
mistake proof the system,
such that we don't allow
that kind of fraud anymore.
We kind of got ahead of it.
So I think that was one of
the cool projects we worked on
for sure.
That's so rad.
Thanks for sharing
and putting up
with my very long back story.
Oh no, I loved it.
Thank you for sharing.
Yeah.
I absolutely love the stories.
I see Andy just said in the
chat, too, I love the learning.
The truth be told, I'm
here for the stories.
So I see Caitlin had
asked a question earlier
and I'm going to read
it for you because I
know you're in a cafe.
But the question was, what did
your journey to leadership look
like?
Ooh, that's a cool one.
All right.
So I, as much as I
may not seem like one,
I am not a very people
oriented person.
I happen to be an introvert.
The only reason I'm
able to talk to you guys
so well is because
you are on a screen
and not in the same
room as me, so it helps.
So leadership was not
something that was on my radar
that I didn't think
I was good for.
But I started out
as this, when I
joined the UPS store I started
in a low leadership level
position where I had two
analysts reporting to me.
And I was part of the
same team I am today.
I think the key factor towards
me moving to the leadership
role was the fact that I can
communicate my data stories.
Right?
In the data world, if
you want to make it
to a leadership role,
even if you don't want to.
And if you somehow
make it there,
the driving factor is
going to be your ability
to tell stories with your data.
And two is to build a level of
confidence in the organization.
Because let's face it,
you're going to come up
with amazing data stories.
And if they don't tell a story
that people want to hear,
it's going to be hard to
convince them to still do what
the data is telling them to do.
If it's counterintuitive, right?
Because a lot of businesses have
years and years of experience.
You have subject matter experts
are going to use gut feeling.
Or what I like to call just
their intuition, which is right
sometimes, but
sometimes it's not.
So I think a big
factor, at least
in my success and
my current role,
was the fact that
I was able to build
better confidence in our data.
And the way I did that was
the first thing we did was we
had data sitting in so many
different databases, Excel
files, what have you.
We started working towards
one source of the truth.
Right?
We're still not
there five years in.
I'm telling you.
We're still not there, and it's
a long, long journey there.
But at least we're working
towards it improving your data
quality.
Second was, I'll
give you an example.
So we have a model
that forecasts
store wide sales for the month.
That helps us understand
how much revenue we're
going to generate, that
helps us understand
how much we can spend for
projects, how we can manage
our expenses for the month.
Right?
It all trickles down.
So we used to send this
forecast to the accounting group
to let them know, hey, we're
going to make plan or not
make plan.
So you need to cut
back on expenses.
Or hey, maybe this
is a good month
to have some
additional expenses.
Before five years ago,
the way it was done
was if we had a forecast, we
would always tone it down.
Because we were afraid what
if the models are wrong?
Right?
And our model wasn't great.
But with the course of
time, we built a model
that was so strong and
robust that eventually we
just let the model.
Today, I don't even tell
people it's just there.
It's sitting there,
people can go look at it.
And we're like, oh, OK,
we're going to make plan
or we're not.
Right?
So it was a journey
to get to a point
where people have
confidence in the data.
So if you're one of those people
who can drive improvements, who
can build confidence and
share your data stories
and communicate it to
a non data environment,
to someone who doesn't
understand anything about data,
then you're on the path for
leadership is how I'll say it.
Of course, the
other aspect of it
is managing people, which I
have learned through experience
as a type-a who is striving
to get everything perfect.
I do struggle with balancing
empathy with accountability.
But I think
experience teaches you
that as long as you're open
to learning and realizing
that you have to
change your ways,
you can't manage
everyone the same way.
So the path to managing people
is just learn with experience.
That's how I'll say it.
I hope that answers
the question.
I know it was a
very long answer.
It's a really great advice.
Thank you.
Alan, I had asked
a question, too.
Do you want to jump in next?
Yeah.
I sure will.
So much of this really
resonates thinking
about what overlap between what
your team no matter is doing
and what my team is doing.
And with a team that's
a small like yours
but has really, really broad
like sets of responsibilities,
I wonder what your approach
is with the team thinking
about professional development
and skill building, when it's
really hard to say
like your work is
going to be, your work is going
to look like data engineering.
Or your work is going to
look like data science.
Balancing everybody's
expectations and career goals
in a small team like that
with lots of responsibilities
has got to be really hard.
And so I wonder what
that looks like for you?
That's a great question.
I've been in this leader
position for two years now.
And I am so proud of how
far this team has come.
I have to say, I can't
take all the credit,
and I won't take any credit.
But I am very glad that
I have a very good team.
I have a very reliable team.
So I'm going to say that.
They're amazing, they're
awesome, I love them.
So part of it is
because they're awesome.
Right?
The second half of it is I've
been trying to focus on, look,
being in data science,
managing a data science team is
different than
managing a team that's
operations driven or a
team that's product driven.
Or even a team that's a
software engineer team.
Right?
It's different
because problems that
come to a data science team
are not always well defined.
And the solution is
not a cookie cutter.
There's no right answer,
there's no wrong answer.
You have the research oriented
approach to what we do.
So what you need is that
drive to keep learning.
And not everybody
has that drive.
So that is something that we've
been working on as a team.
So here's what we do.
We have been doing.
We have, my whole
team has the option
of picking their
learning platform.
Some will pick Coursera,
some are going to pick,
I want to attend a virtual
summit by Power BI.
Or I want to buy
this book, whatever.
You tell me what your
best learning approach is
and you can have it.
Right?
Make sure.
And the team is also
encouraged to spend like block
off time on your calendar.
X hours a week or
x hours a month,
whatever you like to
focus on learning.
And put it on your calendar.
No one's going to bother you.
Do we do it?
Sometimes.
They'll block it off and
then they won't do it.
It happens to the best of us.
The other thing I started
doing is every year
around the middle of the year we
have kind of a week long group
camp, as I call it.
Where we bring in a
certified, so we've
been doing R I've
been focusing, my team
has been focusing on R for
the last two years at least.
So what we had as a certified
instructor come in and just
work on little
projects with the team.
So we had a week
long group camp where
the team was not
bothered by anyone just
to focus on learning.
And then the third
thing, and I think
this is where it kind
of closes the gap,
is you can learn
everything online.
You can learn from instructors.
But then when you have to
apply it in the real world
it's not a one to
one translation.
Real world data is not
normally distributed.
Real world data has noise in it.
It doesn't work.
So what we started
doing is we started
having monthly sessions.
One, we started out with
best practice sessions,
where one of the team
members would say,
hey look, this is a project
I worked on and here's how
I approach the problem.
So this helps someone that's
new on the team, someone
that's learning that
software to kind of get
some exposure to it.
The other thing we started
doing more recently
is we said, you know, what
we're kind of maxing out
on our best practice sessions.
We have nothing to
share at some point.
So we started doing
a micro assignment.
So I have a very, I don't know
if she's on the call today.
But she was going to join.
My team member Liz, she's
the supervisor of the group,
or part of the group.
She puts together
micro assignments
for the team with
real work data.
Like hey, look at
these online reviews,
look at this customer data,
or look at our sales data.
And perform these
operations in R.
Because this year our
last year our goal was R.
And the team would
do those assignments.
A month later, when she
gives them a new assignment,
we meet to discuss how everyone
approached their assignment.
And you learn a lot.
You learn more when
you make mistakes
than when you
successfully complete
an assignment in my mind.
So I think that helped the team
kind of get their feet wet,
if you will, with R.
Two years ago the
same with Power BI.
Right?
So two years ago, our
goal was Power BI.
Now we switch to R. We'll
pick something for this year.
And that's how we've been
doing it for the team.
I hope that answers
your question, Alan.
It does.
It's great.
Thank you.
I love that idea of
micro assignments
and really, really
like the emphasis
on learning and kind of
letting people drive a path
that they're interested in.
If we come back
around to it, it'd
be great to hear more about
how you manage expectations
that people have of, well
I'm learning this stuff,
but I'm not getting to use it.
So maybe I'll plant that seed.
I don't want to
keep going, I want
to hear what other folks are
interested in talking about.
But thank you.
I will add one
other thing, Alan.
Actually, two other things.
The other thing that, because
my team does so many things,
we have predictive,
we have descriptive,
we have data engineering, a
little bit of data engineering,
not as much.
We also put together like a
central kind of repository
where we have reference
guides, best practices,
a lot of documentation.
To the point where
it is someone new
joins my team, all I'm
going to tell them is hey,
look you're going to
spend your first week just
reading everything that's
on that repository.
So that gives-- and
then ask questions.
So I think documentation,
process documentation
plays a very important role.
And it allows us to kind of
cover for each other, right?
Because we want to
rely on processes
that make our
people's lives easier.
As opposed to saying, Oh hey,
Matt's out of office today
so this work's not
going to get done.
So that's one.
And then setting
expectations is you just
have to realize that
you may learn something
and you may not get a chance
to apply it in the real world.
Because organizations
are not always
ready for machine learning.
They're not ready.
They're not there yet to use
these fun cool things and data.
You still have to
clean the data,
you have to do the
grunt work, you
have to do the non-fun aspects
to get to the fun aspect.
But don't wait for someone
to come ask you to apply it.
You know where the data is.
You know what you've learned.
If you really want to
apply it, go apply it.
And if you can build something
that's useful and adds value,
hey, I'll make sure the
organization uses it.
So that's how I approach that.
That's great.
I love it.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Andey, I see you have
your hand raised,
you want to jump in next?
ANDEY NUNES: Sure.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Hi.
My question is so
you just mentioned
that you have sort of a
landing page for folks that are
onboarding that come in new.
And our group where I work was
talking about putting together
a Teams channel.
And I'm wondering if you have
some tips on just some of the
must haves for setting up a
space like that for your team.
Sure.
So what we use, so
our organization
uses office 365 for most things.
So we have an R teams group.
We don't have a channel yet,
because we're a small team,
we don't really need a channel.
But we have a SharePoint.
SharePoint is where all
my documentation sits.
But it doesn't have to
be SharePoint as long
as it's a collaborative platform
where everyone can access it.
So I don't know if
you use Google Drive.
Start with the simple platforms.
We can get to a
point where we are
able to use Azure DevOps
or Azure data lake or Git
or what have you.
But I started with
something very simple.
It's Microsoft Word documents
posted on SharePoint.
Eventually, today that
folder looks beautiful.
It's got subfolders,
it's got everything.
But when I started
it was one folder
with the Word document in it.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
We're also using Microsoft
Teams in SharePoint.
So I think that's
where we're starting.
Thanks.
Sure.
So as you were explaining
those micro assignments
and monthly sessions and you
mentioned that week long boot
camp.
I realized Katherine and
I had the same question
at the same time.
Katherine and I were slacking.
But did you have to
convince your leadership
that the team should be
given a week for learning
and to not be bothered
by other things?
Well, not really.
Again, I consider
myself very fortunate
because I've had amazing
leaders and an amazing team.
So I've had an environment
where I've been able to succeed.
And I realize that not
everyone has that privilege.
But there have been, so when
it comes to the business
has to go on, right
during that week.
So the way I've been doing it is
I set expectations weeks ahead.
So today the way people come to
us with data requests, again,
I use SharePoint for that.
I build up a form
where people can
go in and submit their requests
with all their requirements.
Of course, sometimes people
don't know what they want.
So that's where the data
person has to tell them,
hey, this is what
the data looks like.
But I have a platform where they
can go submit these requests.
So maybe three weeks
ahead of the training,
I just set expectations
with all the managers
letting them know,
hey, we're going
to be in training that week.
So the turnaround time
for these requests
is not going to be as quick.
So if you have anything that you
can plan ahead for, plan ahead.
And if an emergency
situation arises that week,
then I would be the one that
bows out and takes care of it.
Thankfully, I do have
the technical, not,
I realize not all leaders
have the technical expertise
to do what their teams do.
But because I've kind of come
from where the team is today,
I can manage most emergencies.
So I just, I was
the one on call.
And then I had one of my
supervisors on call with me
in the event we had to step out.
Two years ago, I did
have to step out a lot.
This year, last year I did
not have to step out at all.
So it just depends on what's
happening at work that week.
But I made sure that
the analyst and the team
were not disturbed.
That's great.
Thank you.
Sure.
Eric, I see you
asked a question.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
I've done great, great hearing
your perspective on these.
Really appreciate it.
And I really agree
with the emphasis
you said on helping teams
improve the process of not
just doing the technical
work but helping others
on that journey, especially
with documentation,
internal resources.
But what I've seen is sometimes
leadership up in the chain,
so to speak, don't
really see the value
of that side of
the work as opposed
to just getting that
technical deadline done
or getting that piece.
I'm curious what your take
is on getting leadership
to recognize that that side
of it of helping people,
as you said the glue
work, I really like that,
is just as important
as everything else.
Just curious your
thoughts on that.
So you're right.
You're right.
You're absolutely right
where for the most part,
people in our roles
are working day
to day just putting fires out.
And prioritization
on the long term
is not always an option, right?
The way I did it
is I just did it.
I didn't go asking
for permission.
I didn't say, hey look, we
should do this, I just did it.
And when I did it, now
I can show the results.
I can be like hey, look,
when my team members are out,
the business can still continue
because we have tools in place
to help to support the team.
When you give me someone
new, my team, that person
can learn quickly because of the
school that we've put together.
So the best way to convince
leadership is just do it.
And then show them the results.
Because to play the devil's
advocate in the leadership's
defense, they're not going
to prioritize something
if they don't see
that it can add value.
Right?
It's all about value.
And I feel like in my position,
I'm a mid-level manager,
I have some level of freedom
to make some changes,
to change the rules.
So I just do it.
I don't go seeking permission.
I do it.
And then if they like it, great.
If they don't, I'm
fully prepared if that
gets rejected it's
going to get rejected.
I can't tell you how many
slides I put together
with amazing ideas and maybe
a couple have been selected.
Right?
So you have to kind
of balance that out.
You just have to do it.
Be prepared for rejection.
But do it, show the results.
And that's the best
way to drive change.
And one other thing I
would also add there, Eric.
I definitely
recommend this book.
It's called Subtract.
Especially if any of you are
on the path to that leadership
path in the data science
world, I would highly
recommend the book Subtract.
Because it's not always
about what you need to do.
It's also about what
you need to stop.
Right?
That was the time my team
was building reports.
Week after week,
sending them out,
we're spending all this time.
And we didn't know what those
reports were being used for.
And again, I'm lucky because
I have good leadership.
This was a recommendation.
This is something I
learned from our CEO.
She recommended this book to me.
This is what she told me.
She's like look, don't
send those reports.
Just stop.
And see how many
people come knocking
at your door for that report.
And that's exactly what I did.
To the point where now I
have a policy in my team
where if we think something
is not being used the way
it should be, we put it on what
we call a 90-day pause list.
We don't tell anybody.
We put it on a 90-day pause
and see how many people
come banging on our door.
Sometimes they do,
we put it back up.
We're like OK, sorry,
we were just testing.
And sometimes they don't.
And after 90 days,
I just unset it.
Like we're not
doing this anymore.
And I can't tell you how much
time that has freed up for us.
To actually focus on
things that matter.
So Subtract is just
as important as add.
So that's something I
would add there, for sure.
Prioritization.
Absolutely love it.
I'm on that journey as we speak,
seeing some legacy processes
or capabilities that
frankly have stagnated.
And--
Exactly.
Why do we keep maintaining
it when maybe we just
focus somewhere else?
That's excellent advice I'm
going to check that book out.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, sure.
Thank you.
I'm saving that to go buy
this right after, too.
Libby, I see you
asked a question.
You want to jump in?
Yeah.
I asked a couple, actually.
My first question is--
Start with whichever
one you prefer.
Yeah my first question is,
how did you get into data?
Which might be a longer answer.
But the other one,
I was also really
interested in how
you handle failure,
both in yourself and
in your teammates.
You talked a little bit
about that, though right.
Just do it.
And a small percentage of
stuff is going to stick, right?
Yeah.
So I'll answer the
first one later.
I'll answer the second one
because it's a shorter answer.
I read this.
So this is how I
look at failure.
Personally, if I feel it,
I'm very hard on myself.
And my husband will
attest to that.
He's had to talk me down a lot.
So as put together as
I come across, I'm not.
I can be a total mess sometimes.
I'll make one tiny mistake
and I will harp on it all day.
Like, oh my god,
how could I do that?
If I do that to myself,
you can imagine how
I do that to my team sometimes.
They might miss something,
miss a deadline here and there
and I can get a little
nagging about it.
But because I know that I do
that, I've been consciously
working on, OK, mistake has
happened, failure has occurred.
Focus on what is the impact?
Right?
At the end of the day,
we're not saving lives.
If I make a mistake,
nobody dies.
Right?
That's not an accident.
But nobody died, so it's fine.
No I'm just joking.
But that said, you
have to remind yourself
every day at the end of the
day, you're not saving lives.
What is the impact
of this failure?
And if the impact of the
failure isn't significant,
then the failure is
actually a good thing
because you learn from it.
So I love to learn.
And I have to remind
myself every time
I fail that this is a
learning opportunity.
It's OK.
Over the course of
time, and I hope
my team will attest
to this, I also
start learning to do
the same with them.
Two years ago when
I became manager,
I was picking on
every little thing.
Right?
Today someone forgets
to send something out
and my response is, no worry.
It's OK.
And I genuinely feel that.
It took me a lot of
conscious mindfulness
to get to this point.
So unfortunately,
there's no secret to it.
It's you just have to be
conscious and mindful about it
and realize that
the impact of it
is not as significant as you
make out to be in your head.
And then failure just seems
like a learning opportunity.
I hope that answers
your question.
No it's great.
Thank you so much.
And then how I got into
the data was, all right.
I'm an industrial engineer.
I have a bachelor's in
production engineering.
I had one statistics
course in my master's,
and one multivariate course.
So no, my schooling did not
lead me into the data world.
I was working in logistics
as a research assistant
looking for jobs when I
landed this one with UPS.
So it wasn't a planned job.
I was an industrial
engineer working
in continuous improvement,
doing a little bit of analytics,
but not as much as
I'm doing today.
I ended up in this role, I
was an immigrant at the time.
And I had 15 days
on my visa to find
a job when I landed this job.
So I was in Georgia
and I drove all the way
to San Diego for this
job because I had 15 days
or I had to leave the country.
So I got, that was luck played
a big factor in my entrance
to the data world.
But once I was here, I was
like, I'm not going back.
When I joined this role I
knew how to use Power BI.
I knew a little
bit about Tableau.
R I only used for
school projects.
And Python was, I had no idea.
OK.
I learned on the job.
I focused on learning.
I realized how fun
the data world can be.
I had, I was very
fortunate to have
a peer who was very, very
helpful in my learning
curve being super accelerated.
And here I am today.
So honestly, I wish I could
tell you that I grew up dreaming
of being a data
scientist, but I didn't.
I really didn't.
I just ended up here and
when I was here I was like,
whoa, this is amazing,
I'm going to stay.
I don't think anybody wants
to be a data scientist when
they're a kid.
Yeah.
Everybody, we're
taught to hate math.
But I'll tell you one thing,
I loved math my whole life.
So that's one of the reasons
engineering was the path for me
because math was my
favorite subject in school.
If I got a 99 out of 100
in math, I would be crying.
Going back to me
being hard on myself.
My love for my
somehow led me here.
But it was not planned at all.
Now I'm starting to
think what did we all
want to be when we
were little and how it
got to what we are doing now?
I was just thinking Marlene,
when you say you wanted to
or you were talking
about being a sleuth
and finding things in the data.
I can remember like
wanting to be a detective.
and it's kind of the same
thing with data, too.
I wanted to be
a vet when I was
a kid because I love animals.
But when I was like 10, I
realized that every time I
see blood, I pass out.
So that was a no.
But yeah, I never
thought of the data world
until I really got into it.
I see there was an anonymous
question a bit earlier.
And it was, how do you handle
managing the hidden metadata
that is based more in
historical knowledge versus well
documented?
Yeah we struggled
with that a lot.
Because we didn't have
a lot of documentation.
We still don't
have documentation
for a lot of historical data.
But what I started
doing, and this
has been since I joined
the organization.
I'm just the, I just
can't remember stuff.
I hate having to remember stuff.
So I write everything down.
Like one node and
Google Keep and those
are like my best friends.
So I write everything
down because I
have trouble remembering stuff.
And the way I look at it is
if your computer is your,
I mean if your brain
is your computer,
why would you want to waste
your hard drive with information
you don't need to, right?
You don't need to keep things.
So what I like to do is I just
put all that in my notebook
so that my mind is free to
actually focus on things
and do some thinking.
So when I joined,
this is something
I learned quickly that we didn't
have a lot of documentation.
So I just started
asking questions.
Again, I have a
good mix on my team.
I have people on my team who've
been with the organization
for many, many, many years.
I have people across the
organization who have
been with us for many years.
So I just started asking.
I just started asking
a lot of questions.
And I still do that.
Every time I'm given a project
I don't know much about it
because I don't
have the history,
I'm just going to ask the
stupidest possible questions.
Because no question
is too stupid.
So one thing you
have to do is not
be afraid of coming
across as stupid.
Just ask questions.
And write down those answers.
My notebook became my
source for everything.
When I became the
leader of the team,
I realized, you know what?
Everybody on the team
could benefit from this.
And that's when
I started posting
this on our shared folder.
And today we have
data dictionaries
I want to say for 80%
of our key data sets.
We have data dictionaries to
help us out with the metadata.
So it was just something
I started putting.
And now, when we have
new data sets come in,
we ask for the data
dictionary upfront.
We ask that their data
dictionary be created upfront
so that in the future
no one has to do
what we had to do to get here.
So we just started by asking
questions, putting it together
and now we have something.
Katherine, I see you
have your hand raised?
Yeah.
Just following up on
that last statement.
At what point do you decide
as a data science team
that it's not your
team's responsibility
to be producing those
documentations and those data
dictionaries?
And where, is that your
team grows enough that you
can split off like a baby team?
Or is that something
that you find
yourself needing that
you shouldn't be doing
that sort of data grunt work?
Exactly.
That is always going to be,
that's an ongoing battle,
right?
There's always kind of
an ambiguity on hey,
does this fall on the software
side, the technology side
of the data engineering team?
Or is this the BIA, which is
writing Business Information
Analysis?
Is this on BIA, or is
this on technology?
That's an ongoing battle.
Because we didn't have anything.
I just needed, we
needed something.
We took on the responsibility,
did it ourselves.
We got good, we have peers
on the data engineering side
and technology who
are very helpful.
But of course, technology
has other priorities.
They support technology
in the store.
Their priority is to make
sure that systems in the store
are working as opposed
to, hey, does BIA
have the data
dictionary they need?
So it's just consciously
realizing that sometimes you
have to say no.
Another good book I would
recommend, Not My Monkey.
That's something
that really helped
me focus on, OK,
this is something
that we could be doing.
But should we really
be doing this?
Just because my team has the
skills to support something,
does it really fall on my team?
So I just, you have to
kind of politely start
to ignore the things
and start holding people
accountable for what
they're supposed to do.
Other things.
Do you always succeed?
Maybe not, but that's a start.
The other thing.
The way I differentiate
a project that's
for our technology
group versus my group
is I tell the project
owner OK, are you
trying to build a tool
or an artifact that's
going to support the business?
Or are you trying to identify
ways to improve your business
processes using data?
Right?
Because a lot of times they
will come to us for tools.
He built as a tool where we
can enter this information
and collect data
in the database.
But that's technology.
So basically just
defining the difference
between what my team does and
what the technology team does
has helped us come a long way.
Of course, you have
to get buy ins.
So my peer on the technology
side, we work collaboratively.
So a lot of it comes
from collaboration.
We put together kind of a
map for the organization.
Like, OK, if you want to do xyz,
the database team can help you.
If you want abc, the
BIA team can help you.
And it's a lot of just
answering the same questions
over and over again.
Even though we have
all this documentation,
people are still going
to come asking for stuff
that probably BI is not
supposed to be doing.
Technology is supposed to do it.
You just have to keep
reminding people.
And eventually, it catches on.
Awesome.
Thank you.
Sure.
Namrata, I like
the perspective
you shared on failure.
And I'm curious, is there like
a certain failure or something
that you have in mind that
you really learned from?
The failure that
I learned from.
I learned from my
all my failures,
I'm trying to
think of which one.
Because I have so many.
Let's see.
I think my, I think for me,
because the people aspect
of things was always
stressful for me.
The data aspect, it's fun.
I can do it.
When I'm talking
to people I think
one thing that I learned from my
failures was reading the room.
A big thing I've learned
is the data story
that I'm telling it's going to
have many different versions.
It's going to tell
the same story.
But it's going to have many
different versions, depending
on who I'm talking to.
If I'm talking to a district
manager or a senior vice
president person on UPS
or the UPS store site,
I am not going to give them
like a page long story.
I'm not going to give
them too much detail.
I'm going to cut
right to the chase
and give them information
that matters, because they
don't need the details.
If I'm talking to a peer, I
may give more information.
And if I'm talking
to my team, I'm
going to go right
into the weeds.
So I learned this the hard way,
but it's knowing your audience,
reading the room,
and just tailor
your story for your audience.
And that goes a long way.
That's a great tip.
I wanted to make sure that as
we get to the last 10 minutes
here that I didn't miss
anybody's questions in there.
So feel free to post it in
the chat again if you want.
But one question-- and I
think Deepshi stole this
from you on a Slack group
that we're both a part of.
But the question
was, if you were
to restart your data
science journey,
would it look different?
And how?
I'm sorry, could
you repeat that?
I lost you.
Sorry.
If you were to restart
your data science journey,
would it look different?
And how?
Yes, it would look
different for sure,
because it would be more
intentional than it was.
I would do a lot of
the research, the risk
aspect of it.
Because I, up until like
maybe two years ago,
I never took any risks.
Maybe I took a few
calculated risks,
but I was still on
the conservative side.
So if I had to start my
data science journey again,
I would take these
risks early on
and just focus on
learning more than I have.
I did, at some point I
felt like I stagnated.
And then I had to wake
myself up and be like, hey,
go back, learn more.
This is not the end of it.
So if I had to start
over I would definitely
take more risks early
on and maybe I'd
be better off than I am today.
Well, you sound great.
I see so many people are
asking or saying you would
be a great manager to work for.
So I did want to
ask if your team has
any open roles or
anything that you would
want to share in the chat, too?
I don't have any
open roles right now,
but UPS is a large
company, right?
So I'm sure there are
openings across the country.
What I can do is I'm sure
you all have my LinkedIn,
but I'm going to drop
it in the chat anyway.
Feel free to send me an invite.
Feel free to connect with me.
I also have some free slots
I open up on my calendar.
If you go to my link, actually
I'm gonna just post that, too.
I have free slots on my,
I have paid slots, too.
But I have free
slots, too, if you
would like to have a one on one
chat with me about anything.
If you just want to say Hi.
If you want to just
talk about data or dogs,
I'm happy to do that.
I love that you do that.
When did you start doing that?
What's the story behind it?
Yeah, there is.
So last year I
completed my five,
I had celebrated my 15
anniversary with UPS store.
And I'm a manager
now, so I have to,
I can't just focus
on my data skills,
I want to also focus
on my people skills.
I realized that this
was a great time
to kind of step out
outside my comfort zone
and do what I am
most anxious to do,
which is interact with people.
So I joined the mentoring
club as a mentor,
where I met a lot
of good people.
A lot of people starting
out in data science.
And I got to network a lot.
But I just didn't like the way
the mentoring club was set up,
in the sense that I didn't
have a lot of flexibility
with calendar and scheduling
and things like that.
And I was like, why do I
need the mentoring club?
I can just do this on my own.
And so I just put around like
December is when I was like,
all right, I'm going to
put out a link on my own
and I created some slots on
my calendar and it's been fun.
I get to see, like I get to meet
a lot of interesting people.
I met someone from,
of course, India.
I'm from India.
So a lot of Indian
aspiring data scientists.
But I met someone from Africa,
there was someone from Canada.
It's fun.
You know?
Most of the times people
take to the free one
on one introductory session.
So I'm going to the one-on-one
where I can help with resumes
and help with specific data
problems and things like that.
But it's a lot of fun.
It's something I do on the side.
And because I enjoy data, it
kind of softens the blow for me
to have to interact with people.
So it helps.
I love that you do that.
It's like making me think
that would be really
cool to set up for myself, too.
Like having blocks of time.
Yeah.
You could just connect with
people and talk one-on-one.
Yeah, it's a lot of fun.
Something that I usually
ask in the beginning
and I hadn't asked this.
But what is something
you're most excited
about in data science as
you look to the year ahead
for your team?
So this year, well,
towards the end of last year,
we started improving all
our predictive models.
We have five recurring ones
that we use all the time.
And one of those
is what we improved
towards the end of last year.
And I got it to 98% to 99%
accurate on a weekly level,
which I love.
I mean 1% model error like,
oh, how is that possible?
I was like am I overfitting?
I was like skeptical about it.
But it's been doing well.
I have, we've kind of built
like a workflow based approach
to predictive analytics, which
allows us to continuously
improve those models.
So this year we're going to
do that for all our models.
And I'm super excited, because
it's going to be a lot of fun.
So I think that's what I'm
looking forward to the most.
That's awesome.
And on the topic
of mentorship, too.
Do you have any
tips for some of us
here who want to be
a mentor for someone?
Or things you've learned
in doing this like one
on one sessions with people.
Yeah.
Mentoring.
Look, I don't consider
myself an expert in anything.
The mindset is I'm always
going to keep learning.
But as a mentor,
I can always help
someone who is a few steps
behind me on their learning
journey.
So that's where
mentorship is to me.
I don't consider myself
an expert on anything.
I'm just trying to help
people who are probably
a few steps behind me and
tell them what I've learned.
And hopefully, it helps
them in their journey.
So if that's how you
approach mentorship,
you can start today.
Just reach out to
your network, see
if there's anyone that could
benefit from your learnings,
and voila, you're a mentor.
On the other side, have you
had mentors in your career?
Yes.
I've had, I'm very fortunate
for the mentors I have.
In my case, I was lucky because
they were also my managers.
I've had different managers in
my journey at the UPS store.
And I consider three
of them my mentors
who I've learned a lot from.
One has taught me everything
I know about the organization
and data.
And one has taught me the
work ethic aspect of it
and one taught me
how to subtract.
So I've learned a
lot from my mentors.
And I kind of like taking
the best from everyone.
And I feel like that's
helped me succeed a lot.
Thank you.
I write random notes
sometimes when I'm talking.
And I remember in
towards the beginning
you were talking about balancing
empathy and accountability
for leadership.
And you gave us some great
recommendations like Subtract.
Are there any other
books or resources you
would recommend for leadership?
All right, books.
Let's see.
I'm not sure.
So because you're all data
people, I'm sure most of you
read it, but I really love
the Freakonomics series.
I would also recommend again,
this is not specifically
for leadership or data, but
I love The Undoing Project
by Michael Lewis.
If you've read Moneyball,
it's the same author.
So again, a lot of
sports references.
My husband had to
explain a lot to me.
And then,
Unapologetically Ambitious
is another book I loved.
It was more for like
female leadership.
But a lot about leadership.
So Unaplogetically Ambitious,
Freakonomics, Moneyball,
Undoing Project.
And of course Subtract,
was also mentioned earlier.
That's awesome.
I was trying to put
them into the chat
here right now, as well.
And when I go
through the recording
I'll try to just make
a separate section that
says book recommendations, too.
But thank you so much
Namrata for joining us.
It's been such a pleasure
chatting with you
and getting to learn from you.
Is there anything
that you kind of
thought we were going to ask you
that you want to share with us
or anything left that
you want to tell us?
No.
I didn't really prepare
for this because I didn't
know what to prepare for this.
So this is a lot of fun.
Really good questions.
I really love the energy.
I would love to connect
with you guys on LinkedIn
if you just want to say
Hi, drop me a message,
I'll accept your
connection request.
And if you have any
more questions for me,
just feel free to shoot
me messages on LinkedIn
and I'm happy to answer them.
Thank you.
This is really fun for me.
Thank you so much.
I love the energy that you
brought to today, as well.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.
You too.
Thank you.
Bye, everyone.